hello everyone cross tournament played a
lot of games together in classical time
format the result is 10 to 18 Carlson's
favor
along with 41 draws and in rapid and
exhibition games
the result is 24 to 18 in Carlson's
favor
along with 63 draws so a lot of games
and the result is a slightly in
Carlson's favor in the end but since
Carlson did take the world the world
chess championship away from Viswanathan
Anand the two of them will always be
lifelong rivals so it's always
interesting when two of them meet across
the board this is a game from round 9 of
the world rap championship and Carlson
has the white pieces basically they
played a perfect game until one move was
made but we'll get to that
Karsten has the white pieces and he
plays d4 and iron goes for the Indian
game
Knight to f6 we have c4 e6 Knight to c3
and Bishop to b4 the nimzo-indian
defense and it's still early in the
tournament but you know one could say
that this game will mean a lot in the
final standings III by Carlsen this is
the standard line on castles Bishop to
d3 and d5 the so-called Bishop attack of
the nimzo-indian defense a3
Anand captures Bishop captures on c3b
captures and D captures on c4 Bishop
captures on c4 and c5 Carlsen plays
Knight to f3 we have Queen to c7 and
this comes with the threat of seek after
Sun b5 on d4 opening up the attack from
the Queen and the bishops soul cross and
retreats Bishop to b2 b6 now preparing
Bishop to b7 Bishop to b2 by Carlson and
Bishop to b7 Causton castles we have
Knight B to d7 and c4 now
or opening up this dark square Bishop
death was boxed in on b2 he is now
adding more more pressure to the d4
square and also in the future d5 will be
definitely an option
rook 8 the c8 and we have worked a c1
rook F to d8 and Queen
to be three developing the queen
connecting roofs also preparing the f1
rook for development Knight to g4 and
here on ins idea is Bishop captures
knight on f3 Bishop or pawn characters
and Queen captures on h2 checkmate so
this has to be prevented cause in place
g3 and now on and retreats with the
knight Knight to f3 Knight to f6 sorry
as the knight did all it could from g4
now it's time to transfer the knight
back to e4 and this is a maneuver weaker
players should definitely learn I see a
lot of times when something like Knight
to g4 is played then another player
defense with g3 and then the player will
simply leave that night there on g4 and
hope for the best
but if the knight achieved its purpose
on g4 simply retreat it and remain over
to due to a better square we have rook F
to d1 khasinau places the other rook
into the game and we have Knight to e4
and here Carlsen play tonight to e1 and
ok since I saw the game I know white
knights the e1 was played the idea is he
wants to Riemann over it but Knight the
G 2 to F 4 and from f4 it will be useful
to to protect the pawn that will be
pushed to d5 but maybe maybe a better
idea was nice to d2 to immediately get
rid of this annoying knight on e4 but
okay we have nice to e1
Knights to d6 banana and by and d5e
capture some d5c characters on d5 and
see for pushing the passed pawn further
Queen has to go back Quincy - and now b5
adding protection to the c4 pawn we have
night 2 G 2 by Carlsen Knight the c5
with ideas of definitely nice to be 3
kicking that rook away from the C file
Knight to f4 by Carlsen and now comes
Queen to e7 and here Carlson plays a
Bishop to g4 this comes with a temple on
the rook on c8 but as you'll see a
better idea was Bishop to f3 a bishop
will be more useful on this diagonal and
and after playing Bishop to g4 okay you
do have to move the
but now after Queen to see three
threatening checkmate on g7 onon place
f5 the bishop has to go back
Bishop to f3 and now comes rock to d7
her Roxy to d7 and basically Bishop to
g4 actually just helped on the double
out rooks on the D file Queen to b4 now
Carlson attacks the night on c5 and we
have a Knight to b3 attacking the rook
and here Knight the e6 was played
Carlsen goes for some complications if
he plays something like rook to c2 then
the game is then the game is a quiet one
but the problem we drop the c2 is you
have to take into consideration like a
five this will kick the Queen all the
way to a one and after 94 it's a pretty
passive position for white
so instead Carlsen decided to play
Knight to e6 now attacking an ins rock
on d8 we have Knight captures on c1 and
here Carson played rock characters on c1
not capturing the rook on d8 if you play
rook captures on the Knight captures
rook on the 8 then comes Knight to a two
attacking the Queen and hiding the night
well okay only temporarily but hiding it
for now and after Queen to d2 now play
rook captures on the eight you have to
play better to a1 to pick up the night
and after Knight to e4 and Queen
captures on and we'll pick up the d5
pawn rook captures on d5 and this is a
much better position for black so after
this Knight captures on c1 rook captures
on c1 by Carlsen and now Annan plays
Knight to c8 offering a trade of Queens
but instead of trading Queens Carson
plays Queen captures on b5 rather grabs
a pawn then allow something like a five
and to create four on and to create a
massive bone chain here on the Queen
side but here and Aaron doesn't want to
protect the rook he wants activity but
he will give up the exchange on his own
terms and he plays rook captures on d5
this comes over a temple on the Queen
and it's not that easy to decline this I
mean you don't really have anything
better to play here across and plays
Bishop captures rook on d5 rook cap
Bishop on d5 and now Queen to b4 here
Carlson offers the exchange of Queens
and you could you could capture the
night and he six but then comes Queen
character Sam b7 but instead Annan plays
the absolute best move that is Knight to
d6 this prevents the exchange of Queens
protects the bishop on b7 and if you
look at this position it's a pretty wild
position but it's actually a completely
equal position regarding material and
regarding the position here Carlson has
has to do something about this night
only six it's definitely attacked and
the best move here is Knight to f4 this
comes with a temp on the rook on d5 and
if course in play Knight to f4 it's it's
a perfectly fine position for both white
and black but in this position cousin
played nice to c5 and now it's all over
on and immediately takes advantage of
this onon place rook captures on c5
grabbing a piece you do have to capture
back after Queen captures on c5 here
comes Queen to e4 and in this position
Magnus Carlsen resigned to the game
the threat of course is either Queen - G
- checkmate or queen - h1 checkmate and
it seems like you can prevent this by
playing King to f1 but in truth you
can't after Queen to h1 check King to d2
now Bishop to f3 check King to d2 now
comes Knight to e4 check for King the
king and the Queen and after you move
your king simply Queen captures rook on
c1 after Bishop captures now we simply
pick up the undefended Queen on c5
Knight captures on c5 and Anand is a
piece cut out completely winning in game
but let's get back to this position when
I said that in this position instead of
night to c5 of course and play Knight to
f4 this is okay if you play Knight to f4
here then the same idea doesn't work for
example if Queen to e4 then after Knight
captures and Queen captures now Carlsen
could play for example came to f1
because now the same idea doesn't work
Queen to h1 check King you - and now you
don't really achieve anything
playing Bishop to f3 if Bishop to f3
King here there is no Knight e4 check
picking up the Queen so here you'd have
to you'd have to play something now your
knight is attacked on d6 so after after
this King to eat to move you'd probably
have to play something like Queen to f3
check and probably a repetition of moves
would occur but instead of this Knight
to f4 cousin play Knights the c5 and
this beautiful beautiful game was
created a wonderful victory for the
former world champion which why not an
almond and definitely a worthy point to
get in the tournament so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank dammit pilots for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
both of them will be from the world
rapid championship think all for
watching and I will see you soon and as
usual feel free to suggest your own
favorite game from this championship
thank you and see you soon